jedidiah vinnie for you you're you're a
mother okay
hartley married you know how do you feel
with the what does the interest rate
hike do to you like how do you and
jeremy process it when you're talking
about it at night
i mean truly i'm listening with open
ears right now because this is that when
you intro this segment and you you read
all that stuff it sounded like a foreign
language to me it took me seriously i'm
not immersed in this stuff like my first
question was when i heard this i was
like i'm curious what your response
would be if somebody came on because
people view the fed as the enemy they're
like this is just it's a it's like a
foreign entity to a lot of people my
question was like what if there was no
fed what would happen people curious
about that if the fed didn't exist what
would happen to the market what would
happen to what would happen not right
away what would happen in five years say
the fed
it's gone what happens
the
the market would decide and and currency
would need to be backed up by something
so you would need to have the currency
backed up by
a gold or a you know something that is
would that ultimately be a good thing
though or a bad thing it would it would
be a good thing it would be a good thing
but if you ask the people that are in it
they would say it's in too deep for that
to go away yeah that's not going away
today because we're so into deep there's
so many people that are saying end the
fed ron paul yeah right you know all the
stuff no no no question about it of
course they're getting but here's the
part you got to realize so to the
average person
when rates go up prices go down very
simple when rates go down prices go up
so a million dollar loan
at six percent the payment is going to
be a different matter of fact pull up
the calculator mortgage calculator best
way to show it right now
to see exactly what this works out we've
talked about this before but it's very
simple just type in mortgage calculator
go to
yeah right there put it put a million
dollars okay and go to six percent
okay what's the payment almost 59.96 now
go to this ground now so so how many
people can afford a six thousand dollar
payment right now not me not a lot of
people so go to five hundred thousand
dollars six percent
okay
five thousand it's what roughly three
thousand dollars that's five million
that's three thousand dollars okay so
now take the six percent so remember
that number three thousand dollars
that's at six percent that's at six
percent take that six and make that
three
it's gonna be twenty-one yeah exactly
seven hundred dollar savings so now
somebody would have said i can't afford
a three thousand dollar payment yeah
increase that three percent to six
hundred thousand dollar loan make seven
hundred thousand dollar loan 700k
so watch that
you could have bought a seven hundred
thousand dollar house at three percent
because payments 29.51
but now you can only buy 500 000 house
at six percent because it's the same
payment so if you bought your house at
700 grand unfortunately the market is
saying it's worth roughly now 500
dollars and people are not going to
believe that right now because they're
gonna sit around but six to 12 months
the market's going to say that why
i consult a lot of guys that run real
estate companies and mortgage companies
here's what they'll tell you
the inventory of homes for sale just
blew up
just blew up the other day i talked to
one of the top guys in la that sells
exotics i said what car was impossible
to get last year that's everywhere today
he said a unique lamborghini if you
wanted to buy this a year ago at any
time the market only had two or three of
them he says there's 59 of them for sale
right now what does that tell you let me
say that one more time a lambo that you
could own there was only two or three of
them for sale last year because pete the
bitcoin people everybody was buying them
mortgage people real estate just buying
a buying and buying them no but today
there's 59 so what does it mean so it
means you went to a club
and you're at an army base this army
base has a hundred so soldiers
98 men two women
what happened there the attention those
two are getting which is what happens in
a military base that's the only two
options you got and 98 guys are trying
to get with these two girls go to
another military base it's a hundred
soldiers now there's 58 girls to 42 men
that's the base you want to be out yeah
that's amazing
about the enroll in the military by the
way if you're look if you're the guy you
want to be at the at the unit with 58
girls first but if you're the girl you
want to be a witch unit don't want to
you want to be at the barracks with only
two girls so if you're a seller
last year benefited you if you're a
buyer today's the buyer's market so
what's going to become critical today's
patients and here's what's going to
happen to the seller hey sellers if
you're listening let me give you guys
some feedback take you to do whatever
you want to do with this
you know how you're stuck on the fact
that you think your house is worth for a
million dollars and you're trying to get
a million dollars today don't make that
mistake
you're gonna lower that price from a
million to 900 to 800 then you're going
to sell it at 700 a year and a half from
now here's my suggestion to you let
everybody else have that same house in
the market that the comps are showing at
a million you put 910
you put 910 no one's looking at all the
other houses you're going to get five
six seven different offers you'll end up
selling it at 9 30 9 40. in your mind
you're thinking you lost 60 believe me
you didn't lose 60.
you made 140. okay because a year from
now you're gonna sell that thing for
eight hundred thousand dollars don't
this is not a time to be greedy if
you're a seller this is a time to be
greedy if you're a buyer greed hasn't
changed it's just changed if you're the
buyer versus the seller that's all
interest rates matter and by the way
goldman sachs just said that they're
going to raise the interest rate 18 more
times
18 for how long well how long of a
period this is the next two years she's
so fantastic great so by the way goldman
sachs gets [ __ ] wrong so i'm not telling
you they're the messiah but they're
goldman sachs so they said they're
predicting this rate's going to change
18 increase 18 more times and by the way
even with all the interest rate hikes
that they've done the last six months
okay all the interest rate hikes that
they've done the last six months tyler
has that slowed down inflation the last
six months so so so watch what i just
said
let me say this to you
even
because interest rates you you increase
so inflation goes down right inflation
goes up if interest rates are down so
you try to control it it's okay guys
let's keep increasing interest rates
inflation stays low right here's how
scary the economy is right now
even though they keep increasing the
interest rates hoping inflation goes
down inflation is still going up
meaning this is not flipping do you
understand what i'm saying you're like
so so three quarters because you have to
assume that if they just raised it by
three quarters because last week
everybody on twitter
everybody on twitter was messaging
saying
uh inflation went to 8.6 percent 40-year
high 40-year high 40 year high and jimmy
carter officially is a more popular
president than joe biden and everybody
from the left don lemon the other day is
interviewing what's her name his new uh
replacement before jen sackey he's
saying hey you can't tell me it's like
why could you ask a question like that
yeah how could you ask a question like
that so now the administration's talking
to the fed and saying hey you gotta
increase the rates maybe three quarters
of a point not just a quarter because i
didn't do [ __ ] because we got to have
because what they're hoping for is in
july for them to say inflation dropped
from 8.63.5
they're hoping that happens i will tell
you it should happen
but if it doesn't happen
this shit's a lot uglier than people
think it is so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]